RIGHT NOW, DANA.
>> Dana: DAN SPRINGER IN IDAHO.
THANK YOU.
>> Bill: DISGRACED AND DEFUNCTED
FTX FOUNDER SAM BANKMAN-FRIED
HAS BEEN EX EXTRADITED TO THE
UNITED STATES.
HE HAS BEEN HELD IN THE BAHAMAS
FOR A WEEK'S TIME.
FOX NEWS LEARNED THAT ONCE HE IS
HERE ON BAIL, HE COULD BE
RELEASED.
BUT THAT'S A DECISION FOR THE
COURTS TO DECIDE.
ANDY MCCARTHY, FORMER ASSISTANT
U.S. ATTORNEY FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, YOU KNOW THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT VERY WELL
WHERE THE CHARGES CAME FROM.
I WOULD ASSUME THAT'S WHERE HE
GOES TO BE HELD IN A JAIL HERE
IN MANHATTAN.
WHAT THEN, ANDY?
>> WELL, HE WILL BE ENTITLED TO
A BAIL HEARING.
THE ISSUE I'M SURE WILL BE THE
RISK OF FLIGHT HERE.
SO THEY WILL PROBABLY, IF HE
GETS CONDITIONS OF BAIL, THERE
WILL BE VERY HIGH NUMBERS, I
WOULD THINK.
A LOT OF ASSURANCE THAT HE WILL
MAKE HIS FUTURE COURT
APPEARANCES.
THEN WE'RE OFF TO THE RACES.
THESE CASES CAN TAKE A LONG TIME
TO GET TO TRIAL.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I CAN IMAGINE HE WAS WANT -- WHY
HE WAS WANTING TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THESE ARE THE CONDITIONS OF A
BAHAMIAN JAIL SAYING MAXIMUM
SECURITY CELLS FOR MEN MEASURE
SIX FEET BY TEN FEET AND HOUSE
UP TO SIX PEOPLE.
NO MATTRESSES OR TOILET
FACILITIES.
THEY MAY DEVELOP BED SORES,
SANITATION IS A GENERAL PROBLEM
AND CELLS INFESTED WITH RATS,
MAGGOTS AND INSECTS.
HE THOUGHT NEW YORK WOULD BE A
BETTER PLACE TO SPEND THIS.
SOME PEOPLE THINK WHY SHOULD HE
GET BAIL?
IF HE WASN'T GOING TO GET BAIL
IN THE BAHAMAS WHY WOULD WE GIVE
THAT TO HIM HERE?
>> BECAUSE HE IS AN AMERICAN
DEFENDANT.
REGARDLESS OF HOW HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN TREATED IN THE BAHAMAS HE
IS ENTITLED TO BAIL LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE.
IT DOESN'T MEAN HE AUTOMATICALLY
GETS BAIL.
WHEN HE SAY HE SHOULD GET BAIL,
YOU KNOW, ASSUMING THEY CAN
SATISFY THE COURT HE WILL MAKE
HIS COURT APPEARANCES.
IT DOESN'T MEAN HE IS INNOCENT
OF THE CHARGES.
HE IS PRESUMED INNOCENT AND
PEOPLE ARE ENTITLED TO BAIL.
IF YOU CAN SATISFY THE COURT YOU
WILL MAKE YOUR APPEARANCES,
PEOPLE GET BAIL.
OTHERWISE HE WILL BE IN JAIL FOR
A COUPLE OF YEARS AS A PRESUMED
INNOCENT CRIMINAL DEFENDANT WHO
HASN'T BEEN CONVICTED OF
ANYTHING YET.
>> Bill: WE'LL SEE WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS NEWS ON THAT OR
BEFORE THE HOLIDAY.
A REFERRAL BY THE JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, SEVERAL CHARGES AGAINST
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, DONALD
TRUMP.
YOU WRITE THIS IN THE "NEW YORK
POST."
CRIMINAL REFERRAL MAY HAVE
HELPED TRUMP BY POLITICIZING THE
D.O.J.'S DECISION.
HERE ARE THE CHARGES.
OBSTRUCTION OF AN OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING.
CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE U.S.,
INCITE, ASSIST, AID AND COMFORT
AN INSURRECTION.
YOU ARE WRITING THE CHARGES ARE
WEAK AND YOU ARE WRITING THAT
THE COMMITTEE COULD NOT LINK
TRUMP TO THE VIOLENCE OF
JANUARY 6TH.
EXPLAIN.
>> WELL, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
HAS PROSECUTED OR CHARGED
UPWARDS OF 800 PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE NEVER NAMED TRUMP AS
EVEN AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR IN CASES WHERE
THERE WAS UNDOUBTEDLY VIOLENCE
THAT TOOK PLACE AT THE CAPITOL.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
POSITION, BILL, HAS BEEN THAT
TRUMP AT MOST WAS A PRE-TEXT FOR
VIOLENCE THAT WAS COMMITTED BY
THESE MILITIA GROUPS INCLINED TO
COMMIT THAT VIOLENCE ANYWAY.
THEY HAVE HAD A VERY DIFFERENT
THEORY AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
THAN AT THE JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE, WHICH HAS MADE
POLITICAL PRESENTATIONS THAT
FEATURE TRUMP AS THE CENTER OF
EVERYTHING.
THE PERSON THAT BASICALLY
DIRECTS EVERYTHING, ORDERS THE
RIOT, MAKES EVERYTHING HAPPEN.
THAT HASN'T BEEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S THEORY AND YET IT
IS BASICALLY THE HEADLINE OF
WHAT THE COMMITTEE REFERRED TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
YESTERDAY.
>> Dana: ANDY, WHAT DO YOU THINK
MERRICK GARLAND, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, WILL DO?
>> I THEY HE HAS TRIED TO GET
DETACHMENT FROM THIS BY NAMING A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
I DON'T KNOW IF PEOPLE WILL BUY
IT AT THE END BECAUSE THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL REPORTS TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND REPORTS
TO GARLAND.
ALL PROSECUTORIAL AUTHORITY
COMES FROM THE EXECUTIVE.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL EXERCISES
BIDEN'S POWER.
I DON'T THINK THEY CAN GET
DETACHMENT FROM IT.
IT IS A FRAUGHT POLITICAL
DECISION WHETHER YOU BRING A
CASE OR NOT.
I SENSE THAT THEY THINK,
REGARDLESS OF JANUARY 6TH, WHICH
THEY WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A CASE
ON, THEY HAVE A PRETTY STRONG
CASE ON THE MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS
THEY PROBABLY BELIEVE THEY CAN
BRING AT ANY POINT.
THE ISSUE COMES DOWN TO NOT ONLY
DO YOU THINK YOU HAVE A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE
BUT DOES IT SERVE THE PUBLIC
INTEREST TO BRING A CASE LIKE
THIS?
GIVEN THE LAST, YOU KNOW, TWO
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION CYCLES
THAT WE'VE HAD WHERE WE'VE HAD,
YOU KNOW, LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTRUDED INTO OUR POLITICS, THAT
HASN'T GONE WELL.
INTERESTING.